週刊金融日記
2026年8月11日 第七百四十三号
メモリ半導体の需要と供給について分かっていることを整理します
欧州猛暑で中国エアコン爆売れ
外食不毛の地の品川駅周辺のオススメのレストラン その３
ジャンポケ斉藤氏への懲役７年求刑について
他
web版
こんにちは。
ふじさわかずきです。
夏で暑いですが、香港でぼちぼちやっています。
香港も東京も、美味しいレストランがたくさんあるのはいいですね。
先日は、スペイン
料理が安くて美味しかったです。
また、メルマガに書きます。
フランス人がやっている、いい感じのワインバーでした。
欧州は熱波が襲っていて、案の定、中国製エアコンが爆売れしているようですね。
地球
温暖化の解決策はエアコンです！
中国製エアコン、欧州で販売急伸　猛暑、美的はやさくねんの２倍 「移動式」工事いらず
『週刊金融日記 第六百九十一号 東京灼熱地獄！
地球温暖化で偏西風が蛇行し中緯度帯の大都市に
ヒートドーム』
『週刊金融日記 第六百九十二号 迫り来る気候変動で儲かる企業』
Xサブスク（月３USD）は、アップルやグーグルにピンハネされるスマホのXアプリか
らではなく、宇宙かいはつを応援するためにも、天才イーロン・マスクさんのXのWebをブラ
ウザで開いていただいて、そこから直接ポチっていただけると助かります。
こんしゅうはSpaceXと美的のエーアイレポートをアップしておきました。
フロンティアモデルであ
る、Fable5とジーピーティー-5.6 Proが生成するこういうオーソドックスなレポートは、すでにもの
すごいクオリティですわ。
SpaceX 2026 Q2 巨額CapExとロックアップの狭間で（Xサブスク）
美的集団（Midea）温暖化とエーアイ冷却で再評価よちがある割安高配当株（Xサブスク）
こんしゅうも読者から興味深い投稿がいくつもあります。
見どころは以下のとおりです。
-都内マイホーム購入は不動産価格が下がるまで待つべきですか
-エーアイ決算分析レポートが凄まじい件とエーアイ時代にホワイトカラーが生き残る方法
-ジャンポケ斉藤氏への懲役７年求刑は重すぎるのでは
それではこんしゅうもよろしくお願いします。
１．メモリ半導体の需要と供給について分かっていることを整理します
メモリ半導体株の低PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか？
という、いまの世界の株式市
場のど真ん中のテーマで、論考を書いてきました。
第七百三十九号の需要編では、はいぱーすけーらーの莫大なCapExのガイダンスは、単なる将
来のじゅようを見込んだ予想ではなくて、すでに大部分が「契約」になっており、将来の計算
資源の提供がすでに買われている状態だということを解説しました。
その後、2026年第２
四半期のはいぱーすけーらーの決算が出揃いましたが、エーアイデータセンター投資のCapExは
さらに増額され、より強固なガイダンスになりました。
そして、第七百四十号では、世界のメーカー別に、どのように増産や工場の新設が行われる
のかを見て、その多くが実際にきょうきゅうが始まるのは2027年後半から2028年まで待たねばな
らない、ということを解説しました。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十九号 メモリ半導体株（Micron、SK hynix、Samsung、Kioxia）の低
PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか 需要編』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十号 メモリ半導体株（Micron、SK hynix、Samsung、Kioxia）の低
PERは歴史的なミスプライスなのか 供給編』
また、世界の主要なメモリ工場を全てカバーして、ボトムアップの供給予測モデルを作
りました。
こちらは、Xサブスクで提供しています。
ディーラム+HBM / ナンドフラッシュ 世界工場別供給・製品別需要ボトムアップ予測モデル
（Xサブスク：３ドル/月。
ブラウザでXのウェブを開いて購読していただけると助かりま
すm(_ _)m）
前述のように、これはなかなか壮大かつ世界の超重要テーマですから、ここでしっかり
と書いておいて、2028年ぐらいの答え合わせの時を楽しみにしたいし、多くの人たちに読
み返されるクオリティの大作を書き残しておきたい、と意気込んでいたのですが、意気込
みすぎると、なかなか書き終わりません。
そうこうしているうちにマーケットはどんどん動いていってしまいますから、こんしゅうは、
ざっくりとディーラムやナンドフラッシュが、これからどの程度供給されていき、どの程度足りないの
か、そして、株価は何を織り込んでいるのか（あるいはミスプライスしているのか）、現
在、僕が思っていることを、暫定的な内容を含めて、サクッと書いておくことにします。
【まずメモリのきょうきゅうがどのように増えていくか把握しよう】
ディーラムとナンドフラッシュはざっくりとどれくらい足りないのか、ボトムアップ予測モデルの数字
を引いてみましょう。
といっても、僕が一からぜんぶ手で作ったわけではなく、フロンテ
ィアモデルのFable 5とジーピーティー-5.6 Proでお互いにチェックさせながらぶん回して、ニュース
などの二次情報から明らかになっている半導体業界の調査会社や証券会社の半導体アナリ
ストの予想などとマクロでだいたい一致するように作られているので、良くも悪くも、無
難な予測になっています。
これはバックナンバーに書きましたが、半導体メモリのような人類の科学技術の最高到
達点的な超高度なものは急に増産なんかできず、新たに工場を作っても製品ができるのは
３年後みたいな感じです。
新規参入はほぼ不可能です。
それぞれが巨大なプロジェクト
で、各社が計画を発表していますし、いろいろ報道されているので、これからどのように
増産されていくのかは、かなりの精度で分かります。
ディーラムでは、ディーラムダイを積層して作るエーアイデータセンターのためのハイエンドのHBM
と、PCやスマホ用の汎用的なディーラムでは、利幅も、同じビット数を作るために必要なウ
ェハー面積もいろいろ違うし、それこそがSK hynixやSamsung、Micronと、中国の
CXMTの大きな収益構造の違いなんですが、そういう細かいことをしっかり書いていく
と、こんしゅうのメルマガが配信されるのがらいげつぐらいになってしまうので、そういうものをぜ
んぶ一緒くたにして、世界でいったい何EBのディーラム（HBMも含まれます）が新たに毎年
生産されるようになるのか見てみましょう。
Eというのはエクサで、ふつうにPC買う時と
かにぎりぎり馴染みのある単位がＴのテラで、これは10の12乗ですが、これの1000倍
がＰのペタで、さらにＰの1000倍がエクサです。
Ｂはバイトのことで、これは８ビット
（２進数で８ケタ）ですね。
これが各社がディーラムで、どれだけのEBを供給するのかの予測値の積み上げグラフで
ナンドフラッシュの方も見ていきましょう。
こっちもエーアイデータセンター向けの高速かつ高信頼性の
エンタープライズエスエスディーが、キオクシアの利益の源泉なのですが、一緒くたにして、総供給
EBを見ていきましょう。
こちらがナンドフラッシュの予測値になります。
ディーラムの物理供給量は、2026年の約42EB、2027年に約50EB、2028年には約61EBへ
と、2026年以降は年率20％強のペースで伸びていきます。
ナンドフラッシュの物理供給量は、2026年の約1,100EB、2027年は1,400EB、2028年は1,800EB
程度で、こちらも生産量はだいたい年率20％台半ばのペースで増えていきます。
業界のコンセンサス的な予測では、ディーラムは2027年にいちばん逼迫して（任天堂や
アップルはさらに大変になりますし、スマホもPCも値上がりです……）、2028年後半ぐら
いから落ち着いてくるんじゃないか、といったところです。
ナンドフラッシュの方は、中国のYMTC
の供給増などあり（ナンドフラッシュは微細化よりも積層が重要なので、EUV露光装置がないことが
あまりハンディキャップになりません）、汎用品に関しては、ディーラムより半年から１年ぐ
らい先に落ち着いてくるんじゃないか、というぐらいがコンセンサスです。
ちなみに、任天堂や中国のスマホ大手のシャオミは、メモリ価格高騰で株価がだいぶ暴
落したのに、アップルがまだ下がっていない、ということに関して、エーアイでリサーチしてみま
した。
ここで、重要なことは、こんだけがんばって増産しても、中国勢が追い上げても、汎用
品を一緒くたにしてカウントする総物理EBきょうきゅうで、2029年ぐらいになっても、せいぜい
このめちゃくちゃ逼迫している現在の２倍ぐらいの供給量にしかならん、ということなん
ですよ。
現在の非常に低いピーイー比は、仮に株を売買して株価を決めている人たちが、上記のような
常識的な地道なリサーチを理解しているとしたら、2028年後半ぐらいから、新たに必要に
なるディーラムやナンドフラッシュのじゅようが急になくなり、これらメモリ企業の利益が急転直下の赤字に
転落することを予測していることになるわけです……。
【株式投資家はファンドマネジャーでも無知かもしれない】
このように、半導体サプライチェーンに関して勉強して、世界の主要メモリ工場がどの
ように稼働して、増産していくのか、という今どき中学受験をする小学生でも知っている
ような常識的な知識さえあれば、メモリは少なくとも2028年前半までは逼迫することは、
かなりの蓋然性で分かるのだから、大きなマネーを動かし、それゆえに株価を決めている
世のファンドマネジャーたちは、2028年以降、急に新たなじゅようがなくなり、それでも供
給を爆増させ、一気にメモリ企業が赤字に転落することを予測しているんだろうな、と僕
はこれまで思っていました。
しかし、それなりに影響力がありそうな株の評論家や、機関投資家の人たちのメディア
での発言などを聞いていて、彼らのほとんどはそんなことすら分かっていない、あるい
は、見ていない、よく言えば、もっとざっくりイメージで考えている、ということが分か
ってきました。
まあ、雰囲気で株をやっているわけです。
彼らの語るストーリーは、だいたい次のようなものです。
「中国が国を挙げて半導体投資をやっている。
太陽光パネルやEVで世界しじょうを崩壊さ
せたように、まもなく中国製の安いディーラムやナンドフラッシュが世界中に溢れ返り、価格破壊が起き
るぞ！
」
「エーアイブームでメモリメーカーは浮かれているが、過去のシリコンサイクルを見れば一目瞭
然なように、工場を作りすぎたツケは必ず来る。
じゅようのピークアウトは間近だ！
」
ぶっちゃけた話、見事なまでの「解像度の低さ」です。
中国のCXMTやYMTCが脅威であることは間違いありません。
しかし、前述のボトムア
ップ予測モデルで見たように、彼らが必死に増産しても、それが世界の需給バランスを一
気にひっくり返すほどの「ビットの洪水」になることはないですし、目に見えてきょうきゅうを増
やせるのは2028年以降のだいぶ先の話です。
しかも、その中国の増産分の多くは、エーアイでは
なく、PCやスマホ向けのレガシーな標準品です。
いっぽうで、MicronやSK hynixの利益を爆
発させているのは、中国勢がまだまともに作れない最先端のHBMです。
キオクシアは、デ
ータセンター向けの大容量エンタープライズエスエスディーですね。
「中国勢が攻めてくる」という解像度の低い恐怖だけで、はいぱーすけーらーとの間でが
っちり数年間の供給契約を結び、超高利益率を享受しているトップメーカーの株を、PER
４倍台で投げ売りしているのです。
そして、「シリコンサイクル」という言葉の乱用も酷いものです。
確かに過去の半導体しじょうは、好況で工場を作りすぎ、供給過剰になって価格が暴落す
る、というサイクルを繰り返してきました。
しかし、それは「じゅようがスマホやPCとい
う、買い替えサイクルに依存した単一のしょうひ者向け製品だったから」でしょう。
現在のじゅようは違います。
アマゾン、マイクロソフト、Alphabet、メタという、地球上で
最もキャッシュを稼ぎ出しているはいぱーすけーらーたちが、たしかな実需を踏まえて、
数年先まで計算資源を増やし続ける予約を入れているのです。
HBMに至っては、作るたび
に汎用ディーラムのウェハー生産能力を通常の３倍以上も食いつぶすという「構造的な供給制
約」を抱えています。
つまり、現在のメモリしじょうは、単なる好景気のサイクルではなく、エーアイへのプラットフォ
ーム・シフトという構造変化の上にあります。
ファンドマネジャーたちは、Excelを叩いて各工場の稼働スケジュールを追いかけた
り、HBM4の歩留まりが通常ディーラムに与える影響（機会費用）を計算したりはしません。
彼らはただ、Bloombergの端末に表示された「中国の半導体投資拡大」という見出しや、
「過去のサイクルではここで株価が天井だった」という経験則（チャートの形）だけで、
何千億円という顧客の資金を動かしているのです。
こうして作り出された、この異常な低PERは、半導体サプライチェーンを理解し、物理
の現実を直視できる人間にとって、歴史的なミスプライスという名の「宝の山」に見えて
ならないのです。
【2028年以降のじゅようがどうなっているかは正直誰も正確には分からないが…】
ここまで見てきたように、少なくとも2028年前半までは、すでに「契約済み」のエーアイデー
タセンター投資と、工場の物理的な建設スケジュールの制約によって、メモリ企業は莫大
な利益を上げ続ける蓋然性がとても高いです。
では、2028年後半以降、つまり韓国勢のメガファブやMicronの巨大キャンパスが本格稼
働し、中国のYMTCなどが吐き出す「ビットの洪水」がしじょうに到達したとき、本当にメモ
リのじゅようはピークアウトし、各社は赤字に転落するのでしょうか。
正直に言って、2028年以降のメモリじゅようがどうなっているかは、誰にも正確には分かり
ません。
しかし、現在進みつつあるエーアイの進化の方向性を見ると、供給過剰による赤字転落
（あるいは赤字までいかなくとも利益率の急減）どころか、そこには「想像を絶するメモ
リ爆食の未来」が待ち構えている可能性さえあるのです。
現在のエーアイは、ネット上のテキストや画像を学習したエルエルエム（大規模言語モデル）が主流で
す。
しかし、次に来るのは「世界モデル」と「フィジカルエーアイ」です。
エーアイが自律的に現実の
物理空間を動き回り、作業をするためには、工場のライン、街の交差点、人間の表情や動
きといった、テキストとは比較にならないほど膨大なセンサーデータ（動画や3D空間デ
ータ）をリアルタイムで学習し、保持し、処理し続ける必要があります。
また、人間のよ
うに計画を立てて自律的にタスクをこなすAgentic エーアイは、すいろんの途中で膨大な思考プロ
セスや中間データ（コンテキスト／KVキャッシュ）を記憶しておくための、巨大なメモ
リ空間を要求します。
テキストから動画へ、バーチャルからフィジカルへ。
エーアイが進化すればするほど、彼らが
認識し、記憶し、処理しなければならない「現実世界のデータ」は指数関数的に膨れ上
がり、それはそのままディーラムやナンドフラッシュの物理的な消費量へと直結するのです。
2028年にど
れだけ工場が完成していようと、このエーアイによる新たなメモリじゅようのブラックホールが、増
産分をあっさりと飲み込んでしまうシナリオは十分に考えられます。
さらに、しじょうの悲観論者たちが見落としている、もうひとつの巨大なクッションがあり
ます。
それは、現在買い控えているスマホやPCの待機じゅようです。
今はHBMなどエーアイデータセンター向けに生産能力が奪われ、スマホやPC向けの汎用
ディーラムの価格も引きずられるように高騰しています。
そのため、スマホメーカーやPCメ
ーカーは、十分なメモリを搭載できず、しょうひ者も高価な端末の買い替えを渋っています。
しかし、もし2028年以降にきょうきゅうが追いつき、仮にこれらの汎用メモリの価格が下落に
転じたとしましょう。
その時何が起きるか。
価格が下がれば、スマホやPCメーカーは一
気にメモリの搭載量を倍増させ、長らく買い替えを我慢していたしょうひ者が最新の「エッジ
エーアイ搭載端末」へと殺到します。
つまり、価格が下がれば、そこに堰き止められていた「広
大で分厚いレガシー需要」が一気に押し寄せてきて、価格を強力に下支えするのです。
世界モデルやフィジカルエーアイが飲み込む、未知の莫大なメモリ需要。
そして、価格が下が
れば一気に堰を切るように流れ込んでくる、スマホやPCの待機需要。
2028年以降、きょうきゅうが増えるのは間違いありません。
しかし、それにぶつかるじゅようのポテ
ンシャルを想像したとき、今のPER４倍台（SK hynixやKioxiaなど予想EPSによっては
３倍台も）という株価は、しじょうが未来の新しいじゅようを文字通りゼロと評価していることを
意味します。
と、ここまでつらつらと書きましたが、正直、僕はさいきんのメモリなど半導体関連の株の
下落には喜んでいるところです。
あんなに急激に上がったら、まあ、すでに持っているポ
ジションを握りながら眺めているしかないし、こうして圧倒的な最重要セクターになっ
た半導体関連の記事をメルマガで書いても、あんまり株の購入を勧めるわけにもいきませ
んからね。
いったん下がってから、再びじわじわ上がっていくのが、文筆家としても、個人投資家
としても、いちばん良いシナリオなんで、それを期待しているところです。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十二号 エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株
価21万円（分割後７万円）超えます』
２．こんしゅうのマーケット
2026年7月31日-2026年8月7日の週間パフォーマンス
[EN]TOPIX:      4074.93, +1.8% (1w), +18.9% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Nikkei225: 65606.71, +1.9% (1w), +30.3% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]S&P500:     7757.64, +3.6% (1w), +13.3% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]USD/JPY:     157.74, -1.5% (1w),  +0.9% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]EUR/JPY:     182.38, +0.5% (1w),  -0.7% (YTD)[/EN]
[EN]Oil(WTI Fut): 78.18, -7.7% (1w), +36.2% (YTD)[/EN]
エーアイ株反発、米雇用減がしじょうを下支え、欧州猛暑で中国エアコン爆売れ（金融日記
[EN]Weekly 2026/7/31-2026/8/7）[/EN]
せんしゅう（7月31日−8月7日）のかぶしきしじょうは、７月後半のエーアイ関連株の激しいポジション調整
から一転し、米国株を中心に大きく反発した。
S&P500は週間で3.6％上昇して過去最高
値を更新し、Nasdaqも5.2％高となった。
日本株もTOPIXが1.8％、日経平均が1.9％上昇
[EN]した。
個別ではNVIDIA（+11.6％）、Broadcom（+9.9％）、Microsoft（+7.6％[/EN]
）、Micron（+6.6％）など、前週まで叩き売られていたエーアイ関連株に強い買い戻しが入っ
た。
いっぽう、ドル円は157円台まで円高が進み、WTI原油先物は週間で7.7％下落した。
ト
ランプ大統領がイランへの追加攻撃を見送り、ホルムズ海峡を巡る外交進展への期待が
高まったこともリスク資産を支えた。
もっとも、エーアイ関連企業の決算に対するしじょうの要求水準は依然として異常に高い。
AMDは
Q2売上高が前年同期比50％増の115億ドルと過去最高を更新し、データセンター部門は
107％増の67億ドルとなった。
Q3売上高も約130億ドルと市場予想を上回る見通しを示し
たが、決算直後には株価が９％近く売られた。
業績が悪いのではなく、このバリュエー
ションでは「ものすごく良い」程度では足りないのである。
キオクシアとはJVなどで兄弟企業とも言えるナンドフラッシュ大手Sandiskの決算はさらに凄まじ
かった。
売上高は前四半期比51％増の89.7億ドル、粗利益率は84.6％、データセンター向
け売上高は前四半期比で倍増した。
次四半期も売上高103億-108億ドルを見込んでいる。
それでも株価は見通しがしじょうの過熱した期待を十分に上回らなかったとして売られた。
SpaceXも上場後初の決算で売上高が前年同期の41億ドルから78億ドルへほぼ倍増し、エーアイ
事業の売上高は約3.5倍となったが、エーアイインフラだけで158億ドル、全社では180億ドル
を超える四半期せつびとうしが嫌気され、決算翌日に株価は約14％下落した。
しかし、経営陣
によれば、新規エーアイ計算設備の投資回収期間は１年未満で、Q2終了後にも67億ドルのクラ
ウド契約を新たに獲得している。
現実のエーアイデータセンター投資は、株価の乱高下とは無関係に世界中で加速している。
日
本でもこんしゅう、秋田市に最大500メガワット、日本最大級となるエーアイデータセンターを建設し、UAE
などから投資を呼び込む計画が報じられた。
整備費は２兆円きぼで、2030年代早期の稼働
を目指すという。
もちろん現時点では投資額が確定したプロジェクトではないが、東京や
大阪ではなく、電力と土地を確保できる秋田にまで２兆円きぼのエーアイインフラ計画が出てく
ること自体が、世界的な計算資源争奪戦のきぼを物語っている。
筆者は引き続き、メモリ
を含むエーアイ半導体とエーアイデータセンター投資の長期トレンドには極めて強気である。
もうひとつ筆者がさくねんから注目している長期テーマが地球温暖化とエアコンである。
今
年も欧州は激しい熱波に襲われ、中国・美的集団の工事不要型エアコン「PortaSplit」が
爆発的に売れている。
2026年初めから６月下旬までに20万台を出荷し、すでに2025年通
年の約２倍に達したうえ、６月以降だけでさらに16万台の注文が入ったという。
主要都市
の多くが北海道より高い緯度に位置する欧州では、これまでエアコン普及率が低かっただ
けに、気温上昇によって贅沢品が生活必需品へ変われば、市場そのものが構造的に拡大す
そして、せんしゅうの株高をさいごにもう一段押し上げたのが米雇用統計だった。
７月の非農業
部門雇用者数は市場予想の８万人増に対し、まさかの２万3000人減となり、５月、６月分
も合計10万3000人下方修正された。
失業率は4.1％へ低下したが、これは26万人余りが
労働市場から退出した影響が大きい。
アメリカの雇用については、現在のかぶしきしじょうにとっ
ては典型的な「Bad News is Good News」である。
しじょうが恐れているのはエフアールビーによる利上
げだからだ。
雇用悪化を好感して、S&P500は最高値を更新した。
こんしゅうは、マクロ経済指標は12日の米７月CPI、13日のPPIがある。
弱い雇用統計に続
いてインフレまで落ち着けば、エフアールビーの追加利上げ懸念はさらに後退するが、逆にCPIが上
振れれば「雇用は弱いのにインフレは高い」という厄介な状況になる。
12日にはTencent
と鴻海精密工業（Foxconn）、13日にはApplied Materialsの決算がある。
エーアイへの力強
い投資継続、エーアイデータセンターや半導体製造装置への引き続き強いじゅようが確認されること
はほぼ確定しているが、しじょうがそれよりもさらに期待しているかどうかである。
Xサブスク（3USD/月）で、主要企業の決算分析や、エーアイバブルの現在位置について筆者
とエーアイの対談記事が読めます。
購読希望の方は、アップルにピンハネされるiPhoneアプリか
らではなく、スマホやPCのブラウザからXのサイトを開き、そこで直接サブスクリプショ
ンを登録して、ついでに、イーロン・マスク氏の宇宙開発も同時に応援してください。
AMD 2026 Q2 決算 エージェントエーアイは高いピーイー比を正当化できるか（Xサブスク）
Sandisk 2026 Q4決算 キオクシアJVとHBF、二正面作戦の行方（Xサブスク）
SpaceX 2026 Q2 巨額CapExとロックアップの狭間で（Xサブスク）
協調介入、避けたかった米国債売却の悪夢　「友情」に透けるリアリズム
秋田に日本最大級エーアイデータセンター　建設費2兆円、UAEが投資へ　30年代早期
米7月雇用は予想外の2.3万人減、過去分も下方改定　失業率4.1％に低下
想定外の米雇用減、エフアールビー利上げ論に水　インフレリスクと板挟みに
週刊金融日記 第六百九十二号 迫り来る気候変動で儲かる企業、他
美的の移動式エアコン、欧州で大ヒット　現地の住宅事情捉え出荷２倍
8月10日(月)
日銀金融政策決定会合の主な意見（7/30-31開催分）
日6月国際収支（8:50）
7月景気ウォッチャー調査
決算：住友鉱、楽天、サンリオ、ソニーFG、スクエニ、東映、他
8月11日(火)
米7月中古住宅販売件数
米3年国債入札
休場：日本（山の日）
8月12日(水)
日7月マネーストック
日7月工作機械受注
米7月しょうひ者物価指数（CPI）
米7月財政収支
米10年国債入札
決算：東京海上、Tencent、鴻海精密工業、他
8月13日(木)
日7月企業物価指数
米7月生産者物価指数（PPI）
米30年国債入札
[EN]決算：Applied Materials、他[/EN]
8月14日(金)
米7月小売売上高
米6月企業在庫
決算：MS&AD、SOMPO、アシックス、GMO、他
8月15日(土)
8月16日(日)
３．ブログではいえないお店
-外食不毛の地の品川駅周辺のオススメのレストラン その３
もうXでワイワイやっていた旬は過ぎたのですが、Xでディスられていた飲食不毛の地
の品川駅周辺で、まあまあ以上に美味しく、リーズナブルなお店をまとめて紹介する企画
です。
『週刊金融日記 第七百三十九号 外食不毛の地の品川駅周辺のオススメのレストラン その１』
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十号 外食不毛の地の品川駅周辺のオススメのレストラン その２』
膨大な数のバックナンバーをいろいろと検索して、過去に紹介したお店はだいぶ網羅し
つつあります。
まず、第百二十三号で紹介した２店ですね。
きじという、大阪で成功したお好み焼きのチェーン店です。
牛すじとかネギとかたっぷ
り入れたお好み焼きが美味しいです。
品川にも美味しいお店があるぞ！
という企画だった
んですが、大阪のお好み焼きのチェーン店を紹介する辺り、いかに品川駅が飲食不毛の地
かというアレになってしまいましたが……。
きじ 品川店
東京都港区港南2-3-13 品川フロントビル 2F
03-6712-0256
１人当たり予算：2000円ぐらい＋ビール代金
こっちは高輪口ですが、オーバカナルはいいです。
めちゃくちゃ美味しいわけでも、コ
スパがいいわけでもなく、すごくオシャレなわけでもないのがいいんですよ。
パリにあり
そうなカフェみたいな感じで、大箱なんで、予約しなくてもいつでもだいたい入れます
ね。
ランチも美味しいし、メニューは少ないけど、ディナーの食事もできます。
ワインと
かビールとか、それなりに美味しいです。
品川駅で待ち合わせとか、ちょっとしたミーティングでもいいし、別にディナーだって
いいんですよ。
と、ここまで書いたところで、いろいろ調べていたら、再開発で、いまは閉店していま
した！
まあ、チェーン店なんで、他にもあるし、再開発後にも出来そうなんで、ちょう
ど良いお店ということで、期待を込めて、途中まで書いた原稿をそのままにしました。
オーバカナル 高輪（品川駅の高輪口の再開発で閉店！
）
東京都港区高輪4-10-8 京急第７ビル 1F
03-5798-7070
１人当たり予算：カフェとして使うのかランチなのか酒を飲むディナーなのかにもよりま
『週刊金融日記 第百二十三号 ポストSPでの非モテフルコミット、ジーディーピーせいちょう率急落、品川駅界
隈のレストラン、セックストリガー理論に関するいくつかの報告、他』
次は、ふつうの海鮮が、まあまあレベルで美味しい居酒屋です。
港南口の方にある跳魚
です。
いまどき、5000円とか6000円とかの予算で、予約困難店でもないのに、まともな
刺身が出てくる東京の居酒屋というのは希少ですね。
東京の都心で、この予算で、まあまあの刺盛りが食べられる居酒屋って、もう希少です
ね。
そりゃあ、予約困難店とかならあるんでしょうけどね。
跳魚 品川店
東京都港区港南2-5-3 オリックス品川ビル B1F
03-5783-0202
１人当たり予算：6000円ぐらい
『週刊金融日記 第六百十九号 人生を変える最強の方法は引っ越しである、ドジャース大谷翔平
通訳に違法賭博疑惑、品川駅で手頃な価格のまあまあ美味しい海鮮居酒屋、教育工学の効
果について、他』
ということで、以上をXサブスク記事の方に、時間ができたらまとめておきます。
４．ふじさわかずきの身もフタもない人生相談
-都内マイホーム購入は不動産価格が下がるまで待つべきですか
都内で賃貸暮らしをしているサラリーマンです。
年収は1000万円程度です。
先生はいぜんからマイホームは買えるなら買ったほうがいいというスタンスでしたが、現在
の購入タイミングについて相談です。
日銀の利上げや今回の株価暴落を受けて、高騰していた都内のマンション価格も、いよい
よ下落に転じるのではないかと考えています。
不動産価格が下がるまで今は購入を待つべきでしょうか？
それとも、この程度の金利上昇は気にせず、さっさと買ってしまったほうがいいでしょう
先生のビューを教えてください。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
正直、僕はいまはもう東京の不動産がさらに上がるのかどうか、それほど熱心に見ている
わけでもないし、（仮に見ていたとしても）上がるかどうかは分かりませんが、まあ、こ
れまで書いてきたように、東京の3LDKとかのたわまんとかが、これから横ばいはあるか
もしれないですが、あまり下がるようには思えませんね。
あと、誤解があるのですが、不動産は買ったら、古くなるにつれて、年々価格は下がるの
が当たり前で、賃貸と比べるなら、その下がり方が毎月家賃を払っていた場合と比べて、
下がり方が緩やかなだけで、持ち家の方が得ってことになるんですよね。
『週刊金融日記 第六百九十号 当時コンセンサスだった賃貸推奨が善良な日本人に３億円の損失
を喰らわせた件と投資は常識を疑えということ』
とはいえ、自分が住む家を買うなら、住宅ローンは金利も安いし、税控除もあるし、さら
に不動産投資と違って、空室リスクがゼロなんで、相当に不動産は下に行くっていうビュ
ーがない限りは、良い投資になるはずなんですよね。
早苗はリフレ派で、それを日本国民は大変に支持してもいるんで、まあ、円の価値がもり
もり上がって、優良な不動産がガンガンと下がっていくって、なかなか考えづらいです
あるとしたら、エーアイバブルの大崩壊で、それといっしょに、日本株とかも暴落するようなテ
ールリスクですよ。
-エーアイ決算分析レポートが凄まじい件とエーアイ時代にホワイトカラーが生き残る方法
いつもお世話になっております。
Ｘサブスクにアップされているエーアイ決算分析レポートを読んで、エーアイの進化の凄まじさに改め
て戦慄しています。
決算発表直後に、人間が何時間もかけて読み込むような膨大な英語の財務資料を瞬時に分
析し、プロのアナリスト顔負けのインサイトを淀みなく叩き出す。
ほんの１年ほど前までは所長のおっしゃる通り、エーアイはパターン認識、次の単語を予測して
るだけ、と高をくくっていましたが、この進化のスピードを目の当たりにすると、我々の
ようなホワイトカラーがエーアイに完全に駆逐されるのではと慄きます。
そこで、なんどもされている似たような質問で申し訳ないのですが、エーアイ時代にホワイトカラ
ーが生き残るにはどうしたらよいと思いますでしょうか？
-ふじさわかずきの回答
僕も、Fable 5とジーピーティー-5.6 Pro（たしか、両方とも月に100ドル以上払わないと使えないは
ず）の決算分析レポートのクオリティには驚いているところです。
もう、はっきり言って、証券会社のプロのアナリストレベルですね。
中立的で、重要なポイントを網羅的にカバーして、なおかつ財務諸表の数字をオーソドッ
クスな方法でほぼ正確に分析して、分かりやすいレポートにまとめるという点では、もう
平均的なプロのアナリストをだいぶ超えていますよね。
そりゃあ、この人のビューを聞きたいとか、そういうのはあると思うから、人間のアナリ
ストがいらなくなる、みたいな話ではぜんぜんないと思うんですが、そういうエーアイがとくいな
仕事をしていたジュニアはきついな、とも思うわけですよ。
エーアイがまずさいしょの人間のプロのレベルに迫り、大半のプロを超えていったのはコーディング
やソフトウェアかいはつの分野で、これは１年以上前から始まっていたんですよね。
しかし、こういう決算の分析とか、ほんの数ヶ月前までは、数字のケタとか外貨の換算と
かでしょっちゅう間違えたり、まだまだだな、みたいに思っていたわけですが、明らか
にレベルが変わったのが、ことしの６月にFable 5が出てからです。
それで、アンソロピック独走かと思ったら、オープンエーアイが翌月にジーピーティー-5.6 Proを出してきて、
すぐ追いついてきましたね。
だから、ソフトウェア開発以外で、本当にすごくなってきたのは、ほんのここ２、３ヶ月
の出来事なわけです。
ちなみに、エーアイは「財務資料を瞬時に分析」できなくて、僕がXサブスクに上げているレポ
ート１つ作るのに、Fable 5だと30分ぐらい、ジーピーティー-5.6 Proは調子がいいと１時間ぐら
いですが、アメリカのオフィスにサラリーマンが出社してくるような時間になると２時間
とかかかります（笑）。
まあ、どれだけエーアイデータセンターが足りてないか、ということだと思うんですが。
このようにエーアイの進化は、なかなか想像の上を行ったり、斜め上を行ったり、あるいは、な
かなか進歩しなかったりもします。
たとえば、いまは法律相談も、このような決算分析も、平均的な弁護士も、証券会社のふ
つうのアナリストも、エーアイの最先端モデルは軽く超えていますし、東大の数学の入試問題を
時間内に解くとかなら、人間は誰も勝てないんですが、僕がエーアイに懐疑的だった頃によく言
っていた、まだ、コールセンター業務も満足にできないし、出前ピザの注文を電話で受け
て業務を回すこともできない、というのは依然としてそうなんですよね。
このように、１年後のエーアイがどうなっているか予想するのは非常に難しく（エーアイデータセンタ
ーが逼迫することだけは極めて蓋然性が高いです。
だから、ツルハシ株を買え！
）、あま
り考える必要もないかな、と思っています。
まあ、個人的には、エーアイがホワイトカラーを置き換えるというより、エーアイで武装したホワイト
カラー同士の競争の激化が、いちばんありそうなシナリオだと思っていますが、ツルハシ
株投資家にとっては、何でもいいんですよね。
ということで、僕は自分がエーアイに取って代わられると怯えているホワイトカラーこそ、全力
でエーアイ革命に投資するべきだと思うんですよ。
エーアイが期待以上で自分がお払い箱にされたらされたで投資で儲かるし、エーアイ革命が大がっかり
なら、自分のサラリーマン人生は安泰なわけで、どっちに転んでもいいですね。
逆に、エーアイ株に投資してなかったら、必要以上にエーアイを過小評価する心理状態になりがちなん
で、その点でもエーアイ銘柄への投資がいいですね。
『週刊金融日記 第七百四十二号 エーアイ革命に飛び乗る大チャンス到来！
キオクシア株は年末までに株
価21万円（分割後７万円）超えます』
-ジャンポケ斉藤氏への懲役７年求刑は重すぎるのでは
藤沢先生、いつも有益な配信をありがとうございます。
元ジャングルポケットの斉藤氏に対し、不同意性交などの罪で懲役７年という非常に重い
求刑がなされたニュースを見ました。
元ジャンポケ・斉藤慎二被告（43）に懲役7年を求刑　ロケバス内で性的暴行など
私は彼を擁護するつもりはありませんし、やったこと自体は非難されるべきだと思いま
しかし、この求刑の重さには強い違和感、いや憤りすら覚えます。
私が到底納得できないのは、客観的な被害と量刑のバランスです。
日本の司法では、殴って人を死なせてしまった傷害致死や、悪質な危険運転致死ですら、
懲役３?５年程度で済んだり、場合によっては執行猶予がつくケースが多々あります。
それにもかかわらず、人が死んだわけでもなく、密室での男女のトラブルの延長にあるよ
うな事件に対して、人の命を奪う以上の求刑が行われるというのは、法益の侵害に対する
評価が完全にバグっているのではないでしょうか。
昨今の不同意性交等罪に関する厳罰化を見ていると、客観的な法理論よりも、世論やSNS
のお気持ちに司法が迎合するポピュリズムの極みだと感じます。
女性側が後から「実は同意していなかった」と主張し、それが認められれば、男性は一発
で社会的に抹殺されるだけでなく、傷害致死よりも長い期間刑務所にぶち込まれるリスク
があるわけです。
我々男性にとって、現代の日本社会は、女性と関わること自体のリーガルリスクがあまり
にも高すぎる修羅場になってしまったと感じます。
先生は、この世論によって歪められた量刑のインフレと、男性が背負わされている巨大な
非対称リスクについて、どのようにお考えでしょうか。
-ふじさわかずきの回答
まったくもって狂っていますね。
その場でなんとなくそういう雰囲気になって、ロケバスでフェラしてもらっただけで、
あとから「相手は大物芸能人という権力があったから、怖くて断ることができなかった」
と言われたら、それでいきなり懲役７年求刑ですよ。
相談者さんが言うように、百歩譲って、仮に不同意であったとして、文字通りに10分間フ
ェラさせただけで、傷害致死よりも重い刑罰になるって、日本の司法制度が、もう頭がお
かしいレベルになっていると言っていいでしょう。
流石に、これは無罪判決が出る可能性もそれなりにあるようですね。
ジャンポケ斉藤　重すぎる求刑懲役７年も、これは無罪だ！
！
元捜査一課刑事が衝
撃の解説
いや、僕は、ジャンポケ斉藤さんのことはよく存じ上げませんし、ロケバスで仕事中に、
そんなことするなよと思います。
また、警察が動くかどうかですが、こういう権力勾配があると見なせると動きやすくなる
んで、その点でも、もちろん不適切な行動ではあった、と僕も思いますよ。
しかし、だからといって、そんなことで妻子ある働き盛りの男性を国家権力で７年も刑務
所に入れるって、狂っていますね。
たとえばですが、子どもの万引きは悪いことで、僕も悪いことだと思いますが、悪いこと
だからって、万引きした子供を実名報道して少年院に５年入れても、誰も得にしないです
よね。
10分間フェラで、殺人並みの量刑って、常識で考えて頭がおかしいでしょ。
彼の無罪判決を祈りましょう！
そして、仮に、こんなんで本当に有罪になって、懲役５年実刑とかになったら、我々も立
ち上がるべき時ですね。
『週刊金融日記 第三十四号 柔道金メダリスト内柴正人被告とリスク管理』
『週刊金融日記 第百七十三号 蜜壺自警団とは何なのか』
『週刊金融日記 第二百三十八号 恋愛"過剰コンプライアンス"時代を生き抜くための恋愛工学』
『週刊金融日記 第二百四十五号 週刊文春の記事について』
『週刊金融日記 第五百八十六号 一部フェミニストの方々の力で日本の司法がおかしくなってきて
いる』
『週刊金融日記 第五百九十号 なぜ日本の司法は日本経済の足を引っ張るのか』
『週刊金融日記 第六百十二号 日本でも本格的な＃MeToo時代到来とその傾向と対策について』
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。